all of them must all of their must
nobody's doing nothing
all of their masks
all of them are masked
yeah go on
come on
i'm a community leader i'm a community
leader remember that i'm not here to
cause no trouble but look at them all of
their masks
yo my battery's dying give me your
battery give me a battery give me a
battery
don't step forward anymore
yo
[Music]
no it's different for us yo my mind can
understand the man's inciting violence
and you're allowing it i'm telling you
the community leader
how are you dealing with it the guy's
inciting the violence
explain to us explain to me okay
400 people ask you to arrest ring
leaders in it what they're shouting
listen to me yeah i don't know what's
what they're saying and neither does she
yeah but i'm telling you i'm telling you
what they're saying so we're trying to
deal with it
yeah go on give us a chance stop
hindering us
you're not doing anything that's the
problem in it yes this is doing
something it's called public order
tactics fair enough
i'll take it away okay
apologies for me the problem is if we
nick one person
okay okay that's cool i'm gonna
understand yeah okay i'm coming we're
trying okay sorry boss okay i'm just
recording
every single one of them is must
yeah you can put a section 60 now take
it all off but you're not doing it
it takes time though it doesn't just
instantly you can do it you can do it
that's what it was in place section 60
was in place
they stay in place for a period of time
then they have to be put back in place
and until such time if somebody makes
that decision
what they're going to do what they're
going to do take your masks off take
your mask off then
take your masks off
the situation
you're not making it any better are you
take your masks off listen you're not
making it better i'm recording i'm
recording i know you're recording but
you're not making any better
[Applause]
foreign
is